après un coup particulièrement pénible
je m'enferme une demi-heure dans les
tables et j'ai commencé à tracer les lys
par forme de tête pendant 15 minutes par
jour
ça me fait un bien fou décrocher un
instant pour retrouver son entrée ça va
vous tombiez toit après 27 ans de
carrière daniel ronde ou encore du
plaisir à enseigner français au cégep
john abbott college mais depuis ou ce
premier semestre
entièrement en ligne joue sur son moral
alors aujourd'hui pour la présentation
orale
j'aimerais ça que vous allumiez votre
caméra au moins quelques secondes d'un
spectacle tout seul est assis devant la
caméra des étudiants qu' il y en a
sérieusement je n'ai jamais vu il y en a
qui ont pas de caméra est ce que
quelqu'un qui veut briser la glace
daniel rondeau se considère chanceux
d'avoir conservé son emploi
malgré ces temps difficiles mais
enseigner à distance est de plus en plus
lourd à porter pour bon nombre des 21000
professeur du niveau collégial
surtout en raison des défis
technologiques au cours dépend de
quarante et une connexion internet
en face à ce qu'il pénètre c'est tout se
passe par internet tout le temps tout
est devant un écran je prépare mes cours
devant l'écran je corrige devant l'écran
je j'enseigne devant l'écran j'interagis
et mai
des étudiants devant l'écran puis il ya
les défis habituel du télétravail
là c'est ma conjointe qui doit donner de
la formation à son taux donc à va
prendre l'ordinateur alors on va libérer
la place bon il ya quelqu'un qui n'est
pas branché bonne place depuis septembre
julie rinfret a l'impression de faire
deux sessions en une fatigue je suis
fatigué c'est pas les accords les plus
difficiles chargé courant linguistique à
l'université du québec à montréal
elle enseigne à un groupe de 18
étudiants à la maîtrise
elle enseigne aussi la grammaire à 55
étudiants au baccalauréat déjà en
présence et 55 étudiants qui ont des
difficultés en français on parle de gros
groupes qui pourraient être réduits à
distance et c'est vraiment plus c'est
vraiment plus difficile
heureusement pour elle le troisième
court qu'elle donnait à 38 étudiants a
pris fin à la mi octobre
mon élément dans son groupe il peut en
accueillir d'autres
les professeurs veulent s'assurer que
leurs étudiants suivent et assimile la
matière mais tenez plus de devoirs à 1
qui j'ai 160 étudiants
ok donc je mets tant que j'ai deux
activités dans une classe plus un devoir
belge et rouault x 160 travaux qui
rendent la semaine soit ma nes et plus
humaine
les syndicats dont la fédération
québécoise des professeures et
professeurs d'université estiment que
leurs membres consacrent deux à trois
fois plus de temps chaque semaine à la
préparation de cours en ligne
on voit depuis le mois de septembre en
particulier des plus ou moins
professionnels et on commence à
constater des départs plus attentifs à
la retraite également à l'uqam
le syndicat des professeurs rapporte
trois fois plus de congé de maladie
depuis septembre julien feret n'en est
pas là mais elle a pleuré devant ses
étudiants optent s'cusez moi j'ai parlé
avec eux a vraiment à coeur ouvert alors
enfin je le sais que c'est difficile je
m'excuse je m'adapte peut pas assez j'ai
fait je le sais pas comment je pourrais
faire au tram artistes peuvent former
mois pour faire sauts et les professeurs
savent aussi qu'ils ont des étudiants
qui vivent de la détresse en raison du
confinement et de l'école à distance
on le voit dans les messages dans les
inquiétudes des étudiants dans leurs
besoins tout le temps de communiquer
avec nous pour valider pour être bien
sûr qui font la bonne chose
j'ai beaucoup plus dans d'anxieux que
j'en ai jamais eu ce que je leur ai dit
c'est moi je suis là je vais vous
prendre la main au début de la session
je vais jamais vous marchez la charge et
cour consacre plus de temps à ses
étudiants mais elle refuse de le faire
au détriment de sa famille on aurait
besoin d auxiliaire d'enseignement ou
d'autres professeurs ou chargés de cours
qui viendraient sera embauchée pour pour
faire plus de volume de cours et le
dernier dans le moindre les professeurs
garde le cap
souvent encouragés par leurs étudiants
cd anxieux j'en ai me disant qu su
qu'ils me disent merci d'avoir cru ce
temps j'en ai aussi ça c'est précieux
factieux cette espèce de petite
reconnaissance le savons ça vaut tous
les efforts trois fois sainte julie
grefferait compte sur la pause des fêtes
pour reprendre son souffle
18 heures avant de repartir de plus
belle en janvier je communique piano
j'anticipe ma session d'hiver parce que
je le sais qu'on va avoir des bourgeons
aller dans les armes
jean est encore dans mon seul
entraînement des cours à distance sauf
sam dessous
bah bonne soirée un dernier coup à
donner
avec l'espoir que l'enseignement ligne
sera bientôt chose du passé